hmm
okay
sorry it's slightly late
um
I was just trying to finish up dinner
which I didn't finish so apologies for
that
Liz might um
show up during the stream she's on her
way over
we won't be cutting it short don't worry
about that but just letting you know
ah
yes today is Tuesday I saw that I think
I first initially caught that on
tick tock
the 22nd of February which is the second
month in 2022.
it won't be quite that synchronous again
for another 200 years when it can be the
the second day of the second month in
22-22 but we won't be around to see that
how was Gallifrey when Gallifrey one was
great
um I did like I you know shot some video
there I will be cutting something uh
together uh for the break room I may not
have it out until next week I have to
kind of hit the ground running uh
tomorrow morning I've got a lot of work
to
catch up on and um and try and get ahead
so
yeah it's I I can't promise when that'll
be ready
um
that's the thing about stepping away you
you come back and
stuff's piled up knackered from
traveling no I'm not too bad uh I didn't
ever like properly sink to West Coast
time if I'm being honest and um
as a result of that I I wasn't up for
some of the later night stuff over there
but I'm okay for now
yes I did hear about Ivan Reitman that
was
um
that was a shame
Michael Anderson Doyle member for four
months thank you so much for that I'll
handle Queen Nathaniel Wayne all held
the council you can relax because Dharma
the coin operated uh femboy Android is
here for your amusement
I
praise maybe tone down the hailing like
at a certain point it starts to become
almost cult-like
and it makes me nervous uh
getting drunk no I'm not getting drunk
my partner's on her way over I have no
intention of being drunk when she
arrives
who's Ivan Reitman Ivan Reitman was the
director of a lot of things
um over the years most his best known
stuff uh was in the 80s and Ghostbusters
my favorite movie of all time he
directed that so um that's who Ivan
Reitman is
uh the meeping angel yeah God yes okay
so
all right if people don't follow me on
Twitter
I oh I should have set something up so I
could like
share this uh
um hang on a second
if I no dang it I can't do this
mid
thing I can try hang on I'm gonna try
something real quick
um
see if I can
uh
all right see if I can show you
this thing
um where would it be uh for in just in
case anybody didn't uh uh follow my
Twitter so I said here it is
um
oh dang it I gotta resize this hold on
hold on we we can get this we can get
this sorted we we shall we shall get
this fixed and sorted all right here we
go
here we go
I saw this
at gallifrey1
I snapped this picture no it's over
there
I snapped this picture
uh and to proclaim the
uh the astonishing site that is the
meeping Angel and this has become the
most liked shared retweeted thing I have
ever put out and it's not really mine
actually
cosplay this contacted me over snap uh
no not Snapchat uh Instagram
um and said that they felt so famous yet
so Anonymous at the same time and that
it was kind of cool and surreal and I
think I feel like that
um that sums it up really well uh and
yes Cara uh Katie Angel
um on uh Tick Tock did uh did do a video
with with the meeping angel like the BP
Angel was just amazing it was just
fantastic
uh get that gone
so yeah that was that was kind of that
was kind of what kicked things off but
yeah now my um
now my most
viewed tweet ever is a picture of
somebody else's cosplay that I'm not
even in
I mean I'm happy you did so well
especially for the cosplayer because
like it was amazing but
yeah
it's a it's a little weird
what is the future of your podcasting
beyond what the Frau well
um we we can now announce this and
actually if you watched Jesse's latest
video that came out four days ago I
think came out this past Friday
um the video she did on canceled culture
at the end of that she did a drop and we
can now talk about what we're doing next
which is we're basically gonna keep
going me and her
um we're picking a new show but we are
flipping the format insofar as we are
doing one where she has seen it before
so for her it's a re-watch for me it's
the first time and we are doing Babylon
five
uh it's gonna be called the jump gate
podcast same feed so you don't have to
find it anywhere if you are if you're
already listening to what the frow it's
what will be on the same feed next
ah
when I saw your Tick Tock meeting uh
Katie angel I didn't know whether the
screamer squeal I did both she's
is a delight and she really is as high
energy as you would assume she is based
off her Tick Tock uh yeah she she is
just she is walking sunshine and
rainbows
it's it's amazing
uh it looks slightly like a character
from The Muppets yeah that's the idea so
if it's supposed to be uh Beaker that's
why it's the meeping angel because
foreign
what am I eating I'm eating uh chicken
tomka ordered Thai
any thoughts on the final episode of
Arthur why shouldn't I feel old I never
watched Arthur I was too old for it when
it started airing so I didn't even
realize that they had done a final
episode
I um
not gonna lie very Yoda was pretty sad
to be passed on to hit the gym and
everything oh God I got a context for
that now so uh during my last leg of my
trip that well second to last leg I
suppose technically uh when I was on a
bus from Boston Logan Airport where I
flew in uh on my way up to where I left
my car because it was actually cheaper
two it was cheaper to leave my car at a
at a long distance bus station like a
coach station and take the bus down to
Boston to fly out of Logan Airport than
it was to leave my car at the local
Logan Airport parking lot for as long as
I was gonna have to do that but anyway
so on the bus I had tweeted out on
Twitter uh you know just show just throw
me some characters smash or pass so I
can pass the time and one of them was
Yoda and I did pass on Yoda I
I just yeah I don't
the thing is like there's something that
just he looks like he would feel
leathery and I feel like he'd try to
make jokes during whatever went on and
like don't get me wrong laughing during
uh sexual activity is not only okay it's
welcome it means everyone's relaxed or
having fun but there's a difference
between laughing because ah this is
great and laughing because you made a
bad joke and went
thank you
I don't need that
how many cats would fit inside your
jumper uh well it's it's a crop top so
not many
um
uh watch the final episode of the first
season of Peace Oh you mean Peacemaker
I'm assuming you mean
um they're my hope
um
I need I still haven't watched I still
haven't watched the finale like it was
my intention to watch it like during
down time at the hotel during the con
but I really didn't have any down time
not meaningfully
um plus the Wi-Fi sucked Hilton at LAX
is kind of a crap Hotel Hilton at Logan
quite nice same chain vastly different
uh oh Mountain heartbeat thank you for
the hearts here's one for you I
appreciate that greatly oh I didn't
point out
um
cards are a response to uh super chats
which is the one of two ways to
guarantee that I will read your comment
the other one being if you are
supporting me on patreon you get access
to the Council of Geeks Discord which
has a channel for questions to be asked
on this on the Stream So if you aren't
there then the uh the super chats
guarantees that I will read your
commenter question I do try and keep up
with the chat but I make no guarantees
otherwise and it gets you a heart from
me
ah
wait jokes during sex is a bad thing I
didn't say it's a bad thing it depends
it depends on who you're with some
people will probably go for sex sex
storing jokes jokes during sex sexory
jokes makes it seem like an orgy's just
gonna break out during a stand-up set
I'm not sure I've ever heard any comedy
that good
have you seen the cuphead show on
Netflix nope nope don't really plan to I
didn't play the game I've seen clips of
it like I I appreciate that it exists in
terms of Reviving that uh sort of high
energy
um Fleischer style animation it's not my
favorite era of Animation so doing a
Pastiche on it not really going to be my
hook you know but I appreciate that it's
around that it exists
high voltage thank you so very much for
the Super Chat love that you're looking
at Steven Universe one of the few shows
I can re-watch over and over again yes I
need to I need to shoot my review for
season three before I start forgetting
what was in that season specifically
all right because I finished watching
that with my kiddo a little bit before I
left for the con uh but uh unfortunate
unfortunately I didn't have time to
shoot a review so
yep yep again uh things pile up real
real quick
there are some stand-up sets that will
be improved by an orgy I feel like
that's what you do when the when the
comedian is bombing so bad you're like
well we need to make something
interesting happen
I saw on Twitter that you didn't like no
time to die what is its biggest problem
well okay
um
I'm not gonna go too long on this
because I also have to shoot a video on
that
okay you're getting a tiny Glimpse at
how much stuff I have to do tomorrow or
start working on tomorrow
um but
the short version is it's
Specter all over again but longer like
pretty much every problem I have with
Specter is ported in completely intact
and unchanged and just stretched out for
longer
that's the biggest problem I could break
it down into a lot more specifics for
you but that's really the overall
problem is that it is carrying the sins
of Specter
and uh yeah it's
which which is why I worded the Tweet
the way I did if you liked Specter I
totally get that you would like no time
to die what I was confused by is the
fact that no time to die is better
reviewed than Specter was which I don't
get makes no sense to me I don't
understand how how no time did I could
appeal to anyone who recognized the
problems or like felt that the problem
I'd say recognize the promise that's a
bad way to say it because it implies
that people who liked it
um didn't see the problems that's and
that's not how entertainment works but
like for anyone for whom the problems of
Specter were overwhelming and so
detrimental they couldn't like the movie
I don't see how those same people could
say they did like no time to die because
it's the same
problems in the same quantity in the
same
I don't understand
have you ever seen a trauma film I'm
I'm sure I have
I don't think I have actually I know
what trauma is
um I'm well aware of them but no I
actually
now that I think of it I've not ever
seen a trauma film
have I seen Wallace and Gromit if I have
which of the films are my favorite I
have seen Wallace and Gromit favorite is
probably still the wrong trousers which
was the first one I saw so there's a
certain amount of nostalgia there
do I like smoothies I have to be in the
mood but on occasion
my granddaughter got me into Steven
Universe and Gravity Falls I showed her
Ruby and Doctor Who well Steven Universe
and Gravity Falls are you know things I
actually watch with my kid so
Specter sucked way more than no time
tonight it really didn't
it really didn't
because no time to die is built on
Specter and the bits that are better
than Specter arguably are just tacked
onto the side of it they didn't replace
the bad stuff inspector They just added
more stuff which made it almost a
three-hour freaking slog and I saw
people actually on Twitter say it was
well paced I was like excuse me
what
have I played Zelda you've got to be
more specific than that Epsilon that is
a massive franchise I've played some of
it
ever play D D I am on a DND podcast not
podcast twitch stream I can talk I know
words I know what I do quiet
I do too
um
yeah no I'm on uh Quillen sword on uh
Partridge quilt on Twitch every other
Thursday
well supposedly we've missed the last
couple because we really want to have
everybody there for what's
for what's been going down lately and um
well I was actually the hold up last
time I was supposed to already be landed
excuse me by the time the stream was
supposed to start so it was my plan to
uh do the do my part from the hotel that
ended up not happening because my flight
out to LA was a nightmare
everything else went fine so it really
did seem like I just piled up all the
stuff that was that could have gone
wrong into the um
uh the process of getting out there
my granddaughter's 15. oh
yeah I can't always tell
I'm bad at guessing ages
Steven Universe wait until you get to
the Gym's Homeworld don't no spoils
um verotaku no bad talk too oh whatever
oh yeah Zach I'd be careful about that
that's kind of a big spoiler like I
caught that by accident I caught that
because
the ladies on kill James Bond dropped
that spoiler which as much as I like
that podcast I'm annoyed with the mad I
didn't know that
or at least I shouldn't have known that
going in but I did so
um
on a night out drink a lot of water
popping in to say hi hi there Louis what
is why am I buzzing
hang on
sorry about that
uh oh uh John vinyls thank you so much
for the Super Chat have ever heard of n
d Stevenson
I
don't
think so I don't know
what are my thoughts on Watership Down I
barely where I know I've seen it but I
do not remember it that well
I don't really have uh particularly
strong thoughts on it oh hey Meg good to
see you
okay
you can choose only one Secret Of nimro
The Last Unicorn Last Unicorn
um
oh Noelle Stevens oh okay I I wondered
if that's who you were referring to John
I didn't I didn't know if they had
started
um if they'd maybe like changed their uh
preferred name
um Isis I wondered if that might have
been what you were uh who you were
talking about but I didn't know because
I don't I don't keep on top of that
stuff
um as much as you would think that I
would
um
I'm confused by James Bond though
doesn't he get shot and killed at the
beginning of spyfall and is then fine I
don't know I've only watched a few he
does get shot at the beginning of
Skyfall uh spyfall was the Doctor Who
two parter
um he that does not kill him he is fine
sort of not really like Craig's bond has
never been fine he's kind of been
walking compressed trauma that's kind of
been his angle
um any thoughts on the new Lord of the
Rings Netflix series well it's Amazon
not Netflix not to be a pedantic jackass
but
um
I honestly don't
really
have thoughts
which was why I didn't do a reaction to
the uh to the teaser that came out
because
I'm I'm just
um
I just don't have any I got I had no
strong reaction to it I didn't have a
strong negative I didn't have a strong
positive but I knew that if I put those
thoughts out there on the channel
which I'm now doing idiot
um I knew I was liable to just end up
with one more fandom that hates me and
thinks I'm crapping on something when
honestly my opinion is just non-existent
because I'm not moved by it by the
marketing so but I didn't want to have
yet another fandom mad at me you know on
top of Batman fans
um
hating me and they will continue to
after Saturday's video I'm sure
uh
Dr Bunsen Honeydew would be powerless
against the meeping angel seeing as he
has no eyes
[Laughter]
ah good call
and yes Meg yes you nailed it there I
was the convention convention was great
uh it was exhausting as they uh as they
tend to be uh but it was uh it was
really good it was really good uh Joe
Martin was there mandip Gill was there
Sasha Juan was there Sylvester McCoy was
there
um Frazier Hines was there I met him
before he was at the previous time I'd
gone
um
it's it was it was good all the people
who I saw who spoke uh or who I had
pictures taken with were great I uh
yeah
I had a real good time and like I met
some people who like I've known
for a while sort of so like the podcast
that I do with Liz the the tough like a
girl podcast that is hosted on the fire
and water
podcast Network and through that and
through people linked to that there were
a bunch of people who I've been in
contact with for a while
but had never actually met people like
shag Matthews
um professor and uh and M Middleton who
have the darkness to light podcast which
I've plugged before
um because they're great and like I I
got to meet them and and a few other
people who who I know through sort of
the podcast is sphere side of things and
that was that was
surreal and cool
um so yeah there there was that and
there was meeting people like from Tick
Tock like Katie and then you know all
the people from the show who were there
and that
there's some very surreal moments with
with some of these people like I forget
like I know but I also forget how many
people at a doctor who con specifically
are gonna recognize me because I go to a
standard like a comic convention I'll
get recognized like maybe four or five
times uh I lost count after day one at a
Gallifrey one uh a lot of people really
liked the cosplay ahead go and the uh
the second day because I was rocking the
corset and I looked dang good
um Cara thank you very much for the
Super Chat much appreciated
any tips for teaching or interacting
with seven-year-old my teaching practice
is in three weeks for four weeks
um
I really don't because my kid as as is
now 10 and
like she's weird and has always been
weird so I'm not I'm not sure she's a
good metric I'm not sure I have tips for
General interactions with kids of that
age I'm not comfortable around because
of that age other than my own kid
um you know the the rest of them I'm
like I'm I don't know I'm just not I'm
just not particularly comfortable around
kids so I'm not a great person to ask
random question can you ski I can I
think still I haven't skied in
over 20 years
no 25
have not skied in a very long time but I
could so in theory I think I still can I
don't know though
John vinyls once again thank you I've
been reading pretty heavily lately about
ND slash Noel Stevenson's childhood any
fundamentalist religious family I
remember them talking about that a
couple years back
I saw an interview with them talking
about that so if they've been opening up
uh more about that lately I'm I'm I
imagine that probably connects with a
lot of people it's funny it's one of the
things on
uh on something like tick tock
that
um
you know I
because I wasn't
raised religiously myself at all
one of the things I never really had as
part of my
um
journey in coming to terms with myself
or coming out to my family one thing I
never really had was religious trauma
and you know on something like Tick Tock
seeing how common that is for
all Stripes of queer people
um
has has kind of been eye-opening because
again it's just not something that's
part of my experience uh never has been
but um
I got to meet shag must have been an
experience it was it was shags shag's a
character
and of course it was amazing you look
sexy in that corset thank you uh yeah
the
I'll tell you my uh
I my body was not happy being in that
corset for as long as I was in it but
damn did I look good
um convention swag I did not come away
with as much as you would think
um mostly like the big things that I
came away with were were the pictures I
took with some of the attendees
um all almost all of which I got signed
I had one
um I didn't I didn't get the picture I
got taken with Sasha Dewan signed
because on the schedule he was supposed
to be there for one more day doing
autographs he left early and I didn't
realize that was going to happen so I
missed
um I missed that so I have to just keep
an eye out uh for him uh at other cons
that I might go to or or anything like
that but that's kind of the main kind of
Swag I came away with other than that
it's the Gallifrey stuff it's it's all
the ribbons
um that people hand out oh I also met uh
Gigi Edgeley who played Giana on
Farscape had her sign uh one of my
Farscape DVDs uh the DVD case not the
DVD itself
um so
uh met her and yeah so most of my swag
is pictures and signatures I I was I was
on a very tight spending limit uh this
time around I I spent I spent a fair bit
of money last time I was there I did not
have that much money to throw around
um
but uh so I I didn't I didn't treat
myself to a ton of stuff
um because the treat was the pictures
and the autographs
um
Alpine or cross country never cross
country oh God I hate cross country ski
yeah
uh
oh good night Cara have a good night
sleep well
uh I'm gonna be looking for more books
to read soon what is my book about my
book oh my God I'll try and not have
this turn into a complete um
self-shelling uh so my book is a high
fantasy meaning it is set in a
completely original world it is an
electro Punk world so and think kind of
a little bit steampunky but instead of
steam things are running off electricity
batteries
um charged by solar power things like
that and it is a world in which there is
a very clear division between the
technologically driven world of humans
and the Magical World of the FAE who
live in the forest and sort of caught in
between those worlds are what are called
the Elementals and the Elementals are
people who are human but at a certain
point in their life uh exhibit and start
to emit core Elemental energy in the
case of this book dreams of fire the
main character's Ferris he is a fire
Elemental and he is on the Run
um and being pursued by certain elements
from the science Guild which amongst
other things that it does has a tendency
to capture and study Elementals so
that's the core pitch of it
um it's something I spent a really long
time working on uh I'm I'm still quite
happy with it it is available uh through
Amazon but if you don't want to support
Amazon uh it can be acquired through any
local library or bookstore because they
can get it through Ingram yeah you tell
any bookstore owner or librarian that
they can get it through Ingram they will
know what you mean by that
foreign
sorry all I heard was how tight things
were
egg
uh I was wondering what the tech level
was I don't I don't really know how to
define Tech levels like
they're
there are there are Motors there are
there's motorized Transportation but
like most of it's on water and uh Tran
motorized Transportation like Vehicles
anything like a car uh is rare and
expensive
um it's a it's it's a luxury item for
the most part a lot of travel still done
on foot or
um with Beast of Burden uh so that's
kind of the that's kind of the tech
level kind of
uh
uh Edwardian kind of I guess in a way I
don't know I don't know I can't I can't
break it down very well uh did they talk
about Doctor Who legend of the sea
Devils nope uh just that it was coming
out and everyone was excited uh I
actually I felt
um
uh
uh here here's the here's the thing so
mandib Gill especially was very clearly
um
being very tight-lipped and very
skittish about what she could or
couldn't say you could tell she was very
nervous about accidentally spilling
something and actually she did say
something which is going to be the
inspiration uh for a video that will be
out next month it's not like spoilers
about anything coming up so don't think
that don't ask that there's just
something she said about the process of
how certain things happened in the
development of Yaz as a character that
got my brain ticking over and I am gonna
it is gonna become the basis of of a
video uh I have dreams of fire on my
nightstand still I really like it oh
[Music]
yeah Miss Wicked Wolf I don't need you
to remind me how old I am thank you met
up probably with my friend Saba for the
first time in two years today we saw
death on the Nile how was that I still
haven't seen I still haven't seen murder
on the Orient Express actually
uh when was the last time you went to an
impersonal con I'm not sure what you
mean by that do you mean like a um like
a digital one I haven't real like the
closest I've come to anything like that
uh when webcon uh happened a couple
times in 2020 I was involved in some
panels on that but I haven't really done
much with the that kind of thing John
vinyls once again thank you
very much
I bring up Andy's childhood because of
the connection it has with the plot and
the characters of Shira a show people
like say Gretchen Felker Martin defined
as Mega corporate pablum
I don't know who that is
and that sounds like a very dismissive
term for any piece of art whether it be
corporate or not but anyways tech level
turn of the century yeah kind of uh
cleaner than that
um in terms of like real world and
that's by design it kind of has to be
um
excuse me
it um
it doesn't come up in the course of the
of the novel but the reason the
technology is electric based and not
steam powered
um is because it has to be it has to be
pretty green energy because
if human technology
needed to run off of fossil fuels or
burning things the kinds of harvesting
of natural resources that they that
humans would have to do venturing out
into fake controlled wildernesses to do
it would go very badly very quickly so
there's a reason things run off uh off
electricity and solar because they have
to
um well most of the tech we see anyway
there's actually the whole other side of
the continent which where the Alka The
Alchemist league is based
um and they and they have contributed to
combustion engines uh that run on
alchemic
mixtures but none of that comes up in
the book it will come up in a follow-up
not really a follow-up uh another book
in the same setting when I eventually
get around to them my thoughts on Prince
of Egypt 1998 so I haven't seen it
uh sorry I should have said in person oh
in person yeah no uh Gallifrey one was
the first time I'd gone to an in-person
con since Gallifrey won back in 2020 so
it had been two years
aside from a couple of moments with army
Hammer's character that are a bit icky
now deaf and the Nile's pretty good yeah
I feel bad for them because like there
was nothing they could do about that you
could see how much they were minimizing
his presence in the uh in the trailers
um but yeah like
the stuff about Armie Hammer wasn't
public at the time it was shot and
especially in the days of in the age of
kovid trying to bring everybody back for
reshoots was just not practical and
would have been very expensive
those those are nothing to to F with I
would I would you say it's solar Punk ah
not I like I I like going with Electro
Punk
um because the fact that it's that the
bad because it's pretty much
everything's run on batteries the
batteries are solar charged but the
solar aspect doesn't really come up that
much
um but yeah it goes or I I uh
um
I have I took a lot of pleasure in
writing Fae that weren't cute
uh Fey and fairy creatures that weren't
uh cute and adorable
I I enjoyed doing that
a lot
bumped into the who interactive theater
event in London thoughts uh dive in uh
reparticipation or stay back latter was
my instinct
um
whatever you're comfortable with like
don't don't push your comfort level
um
you know
too far
uh Jody and mendip are doing London
Comic Con this weekend are you going to
that too I just said how tight my
budgeting was for the one I just got
back to from La no I'm not going to
London I have my taxes due soon I'm I'm
screwed
uh
foreign
needs to be slapped continuously while
his career seems to have taken a big old
slap
uh I think he's gonna have a hard time
finding work because it's not like with
Gina Carano or something where like just
a certain societal segment has been like
no we don't like you you and he can just
flee to the people who are fine with
everything like it is a bit more of a
like a dude no
um is anyone commission you to review
midnight mask nope they have not
looking forward to more intersectional
content across nerdom and YouTube yeah
absolutely Emily I and I I want to try
and do more stuff a bit like I did with
the disability video I want to try and
cover more stuff like that but I I need
to be very careful about how I do it
um because you know diving in assuming
you know how you're gonna handle it and
deal with it is how you you make things
worse
um Oh Captain Omni thank you so very
much for the Super Chat NASA Punk is an
underrated Punk style ooh I hadn't even
heard of that one uh there's some
there's such a variety of like the
little pump pump Punk uh narrative sub
genres you know steampunk obviously
being the most prevalent
um but there's Electro Punk there's what
uh Yahtzee crochet coined as uh as
Pentium Punk sort of the uh the 90s uh
CRT monitor uh as kiefon kind of uh
style and era scary Faye are more
accurate to traditional myth anyway
cutesy Fair Victorian BS side rant Brian
Fraud's fairy articles are the most
beautiful card deck ever made ooh
interesting do I like DreamWorks
sometimes
when DreamWorks is good it's really good
it's not always good but when it's good
boy is it really really good
uh do you watch reaction videos not very
often
um there's a couple of reactors who I've
like taken in some of their stuff I
don't think anybody who I'm subscribed
to like as a regular viewer is a reactor
I just I guess
part of it part of the thing with
reaction videos is it can really
irritate my ADHD brain because you get
one of two things you either get them
talking over the thing that they're
watching and it splits my attention in a
way that is aggravating
um or you have them pausing the thing to
talk about it which is probably a better
structural thing to do but that can
throw me off because especially if it's
a thing I know part of my brain is going
on pause the thing unpause the thing
unpause the thing so like reaction
videos just don't cooperate with my ADHD
if I'm being completely honest about it
um Oh Captain Omni thank you so much
again a good idea of NASA Punk would be
looking at the light year trailer oh
oh okay I think I think I see what you
get
the OG was cyberpunk oh yeah good point
John yeah I can't believe I skipped over
that
um
speaking of stuff from two years ago I'm
thinking about commissioning another
culture novel I saw that I saw that if
I'm if I'm lucky if I'm lucky it'll be
one I can get hold of a audiobook for
this time
um I mean that's that's part of why
accession took me so long
um I I couldn't I couldn't get an audio
book to to help me
uh move it along a little bit faster and
like having now read it that was
probably for the best I can't imagine
how they would have formatted some of
that stuff for audio but like it it
having to actually literally stop myself
from doing anything else to sit down and
read it was hard not unpleasant like in
my review I did I did like the book for
the most part but I oh boy
my brain rebelled hahaha
uh uh if the creators of Epic Rap
Battles one should be in one of their
videos would you do it I don't know I
haven't checked on them lately I'm I'm
going to say tentatively yes it doesn't
matter because they won't but yeah sure
why not
um I'm surprised that Gal Gadot got so
much stick for the enough champagne to
fill the Nile line in the trailer
uh it's hardly hell no levels of bad
um I mean
a lot of has to do with context too
um
but like I
Gal Gadot is honestly the power in her
performance is largely in the sense of
her presence as opposed to like
spot online readings and that's not me
saying like she can't do line readings
well but I'm saying like as a performer
you know you're you're there for the uh
for the vibe and the energy she brings
to things not the not specifically the
way she's going to deliver a line if
that makes sense
nice purple streaks thank you I I
refreshed it right before going to
Galley with very cheap
um dyes so it's coming out again already
they give the mines different UK
Regional Accents in the audiobook so you
know which one is talking when oh okay
that would help uh that yeah they need
to do that at the very least that makes
sense that makes sense
I I will say like the ma I liked the
mines a lot in those books but and like
the names were very clever but boy could
I not keep them straight most of them
um again ADHD brain and it's not really
a problem with the book it's just a
minoring compatibility with the with the
software
uh yeah ableism and identity framework
models still need coverage
intersectionality is a thing disability
day of mourning is in March thank you
for all of that Emily yes
uh
ever heard of the sardonicast podcast I
feel like I've heard of I feel like I've
heard that name
I've never listened to it
no one said fairies were nice dang right
actually that's not true Victorian
children said fairies are nice
but their children and don't know what
they're talking about
Captain Omni Once More Much appreciated
my favorite kind of punk would have to
be ocean Punk essentially a water world
or any series focusing heavily on
ocean-based technology oh cool oh yeah
and Discord just a second car when I
will get to that momentarily
um
yeah so carowind did uh thank Megan I'm
also going to thank Meg Meg in the chat
right now was uh did consult and help me
with the disability video
um she gave a look over the the script
and actually pointed out some things
that I needed to adjust and gave me some
ideas of things to include that I didn't
already she was an incredibly big help
and she just commented probably good
that I'm just Consulting not actually
doing my own videos because I'm guessing
it would have ended up very a very
unhinged kind of rant
uh yeah but it I think it'd still be
worth watching Meg I'm just saying and
Meg has actually helped me out before
she she gave me a hand uh a year two
years ago uh when I talked about Sia's
music in the lead up to to that anyways
I gotta check the Discord be right back
uh
[Music]
uh so for the Babylon 5 rewatch do you
know if you're starting with the pilot
or season one episode one but if the
pilot thing is like the pilot movie I
believe we are starting with that
um it's it's gonna be because
I know there's some
debate uh over best viewing order
uh for Babylon five I'm leaving it in
Jesse's hands because she's the one
who's seen the thing so I'm leaving it
up to her to decide what order we're
watching anything in
um but I'm pretty sure if the pilot is
the movie thing then yeah I'm pretty
sure we're starting with that
excuse me
um
oh Dharma dropped me some uh some links
to some of the stuff uh referring to uh
to Andy Stevenson
um I'm gonna have to unpack that
later
uh ooh okay can't say I'm loving the
tone of this whoever this person is
um
so oh and finally okay so X-Men re that
trailer how wrong Could It Go
that
all right so this has to do with the
implication
um
the implication of the latest Stevens uh
Stephen Strange uh Doctor Strange
trailer implies the possibility of us
getting the fox films version of the
X-Men which is you know Patrick Stewart
Hugh Jackman
um and I'll and all those folks
and
how badly Could It Go
it kind of depends because
all right in my mind this is the worst
case scenario
they imply that
that those specific versions of these
characters could cross over fans lose
their mind Marvel pulls the trigger on
actually pulling in those actors and of
those versions and everyone is
underwhelmed because it's just the thing
they already knew in a new setting but
um Marvel was buoyed by the
uh by the initial pop of excitement to
do something that I think is narratively
not a particularly interesting or uh
fulfilling or
um
thoughtful
thing to do
I don't think bringing in
I've never thought I have always since
the very first days of the fox
acquisition by
um by Disney I've always said I do not
think it is a good idea to just port in
the existing X-Men characters I've never
thought that was a good idea uh and I
would hate to see them do it I think
it's
I think it is unlikely to yield good
stories is the simple answer to that and
I could be wrong they could do it and it
could be great but for me worst case
scenario is they tease it people love it
so much that they do it and then it's
just
uh nothing
it's just Nostalgia bait
that to me is the worst case scenario do
I think that's going to happen
I I don't know
I don't I don't know what's gonna happen
but I really I really don't want
um
the fox X-Men ported in to the MCU I
really really
don't
and I've talked I've talked before about
why not and I absolutely reject the
argument that
um
that you know well we have to otherwise
how do we explain why mutants haven't
turned up you make something up I gave
my own pitch for how to do that a while
back so like there are ways to do it
that that's like the whole
um thing with the time of the shower
well we had to give the doctor unlimited
uh regenerations first of all no you
didn't second of all even if you had to
do that do it better
whatever anyways all right I've got a
couple of super chats to wrap up and
then we might be done after that but uh
new type JB Lee for any long-running
media Like Comics or TV does Decades of
continuity alienate new fans isn't
reboots and reset buttons uh can be just
as confusing
it's tough so
that they're
yeah the short answer is yes Decades of
continuity can be alienating depending
on how much they matter so part of the
way Comics plugged on I would say for
about their first 50 years pretty
unabated without too much issue is that
things always reset back to the status
quo so you didn't need to know all the
continuity that came before you just
needed to know what's the basic standard
for these characters then you could jump
in at any point jump off jump back on
again you're fine starting in the 80s
you started to have much bigger
continuity shake-ups and it became more
of a case of you had to be paying
attention and yeah that can be
alienating
um and off-putting especially to anyone
new and it depends on how far back the
continuity goes and how much of it you
need to know
to my mind the best way of handling
continuity is to basically avoid
avoid deep cuts that don't make sense
within the story you're telling so where
continuity becomes a detriment is when
you start referring back to things from
years and years and years ago that your
average new person coming in would never
ever be expected to know and it's very
clear that this is only here because it
was there before that's the worst way to
do it in my mind if you handle it well
if you focus on the story that you're
telling now now that is within that
continuity than what you end up with is
something with a sense of history but
you still can just enjoy that story part
of the problem has been lately
especially with Comics is that they keep
doing big event after big event after a
big event and it feels like there's
never a package bundled story there's
like little arcs but nobody ever tells a
completed story anymore and that that
makes it tougher hang on I think I might
sneeze
maybe not
it's because
okay there we go uh
uh John vinyls once again thank you one
of my shoe or commentary was that I
think Andy Stevenson's upbringing
impacted the show's story in certain
ways oh I don't doubt it I don't doubt
it I'd like
you dig into any writer's things uh if
you if you are the type to
psychoanalyzer writer or if a writer is
the kind to share that kind of stuff in
their own thoughts about what influenced
their stuff
um then yeah you can find that in
anybody's writing it's it's all over my
freaking writing and not like just the
book but like short stories I've written
that I've never been published the play
that I published like I I have had my
introspective moments of sort of telling
my head sideways and going oh
I write about that
General aspect of life a lot
uh so like that's true of any writer
uh how would you feel if they got tenant
to be the master instead of the doctor
imagine the master running around using
the doctor's face and selling his image
in confidence I have no interest
I really have zero interest I saw like
when I did my video saying that it's a
bad idea to bring tenant back as the
doctor again
um I saw more than a few people float
that idea that that even if they agreed
with me they'd like to see that I
wouldn't for two reasons one we
basically kind of got that with Jessica
Jones already
I feel like that's more or less Dave
attendant as the master or something
close to it so I feel like I've already
got it first of all second of all like
it would just be such a gimmick
um
so
and and like the idea of like solving
his self-image uh and his
self-confidence I mean
I don't need the doctor to have an
existential crisis I've actually rarely
cared for the stories when the doctor
has an existential crisis so like the
stories that you could feasibly get out
of that setup aren't ones I personally
am interested in so that's me
um
Welsh Welsh wrestling Geeks
Q uh which doctor would you most like to
be friends with and which would you
least like to be friends with I feel
like I would get along with uh 11 with
Matt Smith's doctor uh very well
um I don't
I'd say I'd least like to be friends
with six but I'm gonna say specifically
six during the TV time it became more
tolerable
um during big finish
uh
do we ever talk about X-Files on here or
Silicon Valley trying to determine what
flavors of geekery we are serving uh
Meg I know I know you you have you have
your geekery but uh we we do uh uh we do
kind of we do kind of go on different
ends of it but all geekery is welcome
here all right I think this is gonna
have to be the last Super Chat and then
I need to wrap it up Liz will be here
soon new type JB Lee thank you so much
how come the Fantastic Beasts had less
luck in adaptations compared I'm sorry
Fantastic Beasts yeah Fantastic Four
had less luck in adaptation compared to
the X-Men Spidey Etc the concept is
Fantastic Four is simple how come it's
hard to adapt the thing is the concept
of the Fantastic Four is really rooted
in the time and place it was created
what I mean by that is the whole thing
is rooted in
not only the kennedy-era space travel
but in
um in the concept of the nuclear family
that's kind of at the heart of it
especially when it comes with I mean
Reed richards's father's know knows best
kind of guy and for a very long time Sue
was
um The Good Wife and
um Johnny was the rambunctious kid and
Ben was either the fun uncle or the
family dog depending on uh who was
writing it but that whole dynamic is
very embedded in a different point in
time and I think trying to find out how
to update that has not only been a
problem for the films it's been a
problem for the comics as well the
Fantastic Four have gone for long
stretches where it's very clear the
creators don't know how to make these
characters work in a modern context
there have been a couple of times that
it has worked I think it was Mark Wade
did a run in the early 2000s that was
very good but with only a couple of
exceptions like him there
everybody seems to have trouble making
the Fantastic Four work as core
characters these days
um because they have to either try and
make their outdated archetypes fit in a
world that they're not designed for
anymore or try and turn them into
subversions which they weren't ever
really built to be or do and so that
never really takes either whenever they
try and do that so they're surprisingly
difficult to work with not because they
are complicated as you said they're
quite simple
but because they are rooted in such a
Time past and in a way that doesn't
update easily so I think that's the core
issue with them
but I need to
um I need to wrap it up
uh I'm gonna look into see if there's an
audiobook because the book I'm thinking
about it 600 pages long if if you could
favor me one with an audiobook where the
audiobook is available in the US because
there actually was a next session
audiobook I just couldn't buy it here
um that would be amazing I'm not going
to make that a requirement but it would
help it would cut down on your wait time
um did I hear big finisher doing a
series with Colin Baker as an alternate
War Doctor I did hear that
um I'm sure it'll be great don't know
when I'll get around to listening to it
I need to I need to go oh yes Carolyn
thank you uh twitch I'm back on Twitch
tomorrow 10 30 a.m eastern time
um back with uh Final Fantasy VII
remastered or remake or re-sidivist or
arachnoid or whatever it is so back with
that and
um yeah I'll have uh more stuff going up
on the break room soon and uh yeah
Friday Friday is something that'll
probably get the Batman fan to mad at me
again so that'll be fun
um
but uh did I say Friday Saturday
Saturday's video Friday's more twitch
anyways uh Council geeks on Twitch I'll
see you there in the morning uh if you
can make it but in any case
be well
be safe be kind remember that you are
beautiful
you are valid
and you are loved
you are the council I just run the
meetings and until next time this
Council
is adjourned
mccavity